Zane Chris congratulations you boys have
made it into the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to recreate an
iconic weapon from history
that weapon is
[Music]
the Revolutionary War sergeant spontoon
now I'll be pre-testing the
Revolutionary War sergeant spontoon
so the spontoon is a different kind of
weapon I mean it's a longer weapon you
know a lot of times we have swords we
use one hand with a spontoon you got to
use two-handed and the weights all
forward so it gives us a different feel
of thrusting at a distance as opposed to
cutting with a sword the beauty of that
is I have distance to protect myself so
if I can fight you from here and you're
all the way out there safer for me
replacing the Halbert spontoons were
used throughout the American Revolution
in Napoleonic Wars by British and
Hessian soldiers featuring a leaf-shaped
spearhead the blade had limited cutting
ability however it excelled at thrusting
into charging infantry and Cavalry a
crossbar is attached to the bottom of
the spearhead so the blade wouldn't get
stuck into its Target although the
weapon was a brutal killer it was
primarily used as a signaling tool to
direct orders to troops as its length
was easy to spot across the field
eventually the weapon transitioned to
being purely an identifier of rank
amongst the troops however its Legacy
lives on through popular culture and you
can see British sergeants wield it in
the film Revolution
so I want to test every possible piece
of that weapon it's not just about the
frosting but it's got an edge on the
side we're going to test your Edge too
it's got a stopper right there we're
going to test a stopper too so all about
the movements and trying to test the
weapon for what it can do
the reason we use a boar carcass is
because it's got very thick hide it's a
lot harder to cut into especially when
you see the slash it's not as obvious as
a pig that's just skin because when you
slash into that if your blade's not
sharp enough it's not even going to cut
through all the hair to get into the
skin and into the carcass of the animal
now we chose the spontoon to do that
because the bores are aggressive they'll
come running into you so as I'm stabbing
here something goes there I'll cut this
way or I'll slash that way because it's
coming at me so I should have a way to
be able to spear into the bore carcass
and see if it's gonna stop go through or
at the same time really penetrate to
keep it away at distance
all right
good luck we'll see you in four days
my name is Zane Birch I'm 19 years old
when I was a kid I wanted to be a pirate
but that's not really reasonable right
now so late smithing was the secondary
alternative for that
I decided to use 5160 for the blade
steel because it is relatively easy to
heat treat but also holds up very well
when under duress my main goal is to
elongate this piece of Steel that will
eventually become the blade for the heat
tree I'm going to be using this oven
right here it works really well with
temperature control I can keep my blade
exactly the temperature that I want it
for how long I want it
I am nervous that my heat treat is not
going to go well I could have the blade
snap I could have it warp I could have
it just not hardened at all
I don't hear any tinking sounds so
that's good tanks are usually cracks
and it's hard and I am so excited I
planned on finishing up my blade and
then I am going to weld my tang and my
guard to my socket that's pretty good
thank you
my name is Chris Hedberg I'm really
looking forward to using big blue I
think that might be a common thing just
to be able to hammer on some hot steel
and see how it moves underneath the
hammer I'm looking forward to trying
that out
I'm going to build a Damascus Billet I
got my main Billet cleaned up I'm going
to cut it and restack it get it to the
size I need and then I can hopefully
start getting the point shaped out
the cross guard being set for peace is a
concern of mine I am going to have to
forge weld that for structural Integrity
reasons probably going to get into some
welding with the MIG welder just to
reinforce everything I decided to forge
weld the cross guard on just give it a
lot more structural Integrity it's more
like one piece instead of two pieces I
layered the wood up hopefully the
difference in Grain structure will help
and strengthness and flexibility
I left it sort of octagonal I think it'd
give a little better grip
now it's time to get my half detached to
my spontoon Spearhead
it was a hell of a build I'm tired I'm
sore I think it looks awesome
I cut one I'm good
all right places welcome to the kill
test
and I will take your weapon deliver some
thrusts and slashes on this wild boar
carcass
saying you're off first you ready for
this
right as I'll ever be
all right Zayn let's talk about your
weapon here first up your tip is really
made to throw us it punctures really
deep when I'm thrusting with it but I
can move with this weapon you have a
good bounce here the edge here is sharp
as you can see those are very very deep
Sharp Cuts overall sir you're a weapon
we'll kill thank you Doug
all right Chris it's your turn you ready
yes sir
all right Chris sorry about your weapon
here what I love about this is when
you're thrusting I can feel the weight
in front and crunch ribs as it's
penetrating overall sir your weapon will
kill thank you sir
say hello to my little friend
just the strength and durability of your
blades we're going to be firing them out
of our air cannon here into that wooden
wall
all right Zane Europe first this thing
is going to launch my spontoon my baby
at a wall of wood on the odd mixture
between excited and nervous right now
in three two one fire
all right Zane nothing came apart it
still has the edge that it started out
with
oh no good job thank you nice job all
right Chris you're up
firing in three two one fire
oh holy job Chris
[Music]
okay your weapon went right in between
those boards so it actually took all the
impact up here on these lugs
everything's still straight
still Sharp I really like that pattern
you've got on there nicely done thank
you okay it's nice
welcome to the sharpness test the red
coat stab and slice
the sharpness of your Edge I will take
your weapon and Slash and stab across
this red coat saying you're first let's
do it
[Music]
foreign
your edges are sharp on the swing of
that it does cut but what I do find here
there's a little bit of a glinting at
your tip that catches on my nails it
rolled a little bit right there at your
tip but otherwise sir
it will cut thank you
all right Chris your turn let's do this
foreign
[Music]
Chris this is a very razor sharp blade
every slash and thrust was a deep cut I
do not see any damage to your Edge
overall sir this weapon
will cut
thank you
Zane Chris you guys have done fantastic
work on these finale weapons but there
can only be one forged and fire Champion
the judges have made their final
decision and that forged and fire
Champion is
Chris congratulations you are the new
forged and fire Champion congratulations
man Zane unfortunately your weapon took
some damage during the sharpness test
which affected the efficacy of your cuts
for that reason I'd like to invite you
to shake my hand shake your judge's hand
and then please leave the forge come on
my friend
meet you guys good job brother I did not
win but that's okay Chris you crafted a
better weapon that held up through the
tests congratulations you were the
fortune fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother come over here
and Shake our hands absolutely I just
became Fortune fire champion
that's crazy I'm like turning inside out
right now I got the bragging rights man
I can just keep moving ahead uh keep
doing what I'm doing